first up i want to show you two maps
that in part explain the situation we
find ourselves in today the first shows
nato expansion all the way from the
founding of the washington treaty in
1949 up until 2020 when north macedonia
the latest member joined and you can see
the soviet empire shrinking and nato
expanding eastward and that is what
annoys vladimir putin he believes nato
poses a direct threat to russian
security
but let's look at the second map and
this is in a way nato's counter to that
they say that nato only borders
1 16
of russia i've highlighted the borders
there that they share up in the north in
norway the baltic states and then around
the enclave of klinengrad and if we zoom
out to a wide of that map and see that
vast russian border you can see just how
little of it actually is bordered by
nato countries
so what about the latest on the ground
tonight as far as we know it well
russian troops
continue to grow in number and encircle
the ukraine there they are in the north
in belarus on exercise we've also
actually got some uh down south in
moldova as well we think about a hundred
and thirty thousand now and as i say
growing let's look at two satellite
images now this is the sort of thing
that military officials will look at in
order to try and ascertain what's
happening and what might happen next
this is crimea where we see a missile
battery we have another satellite image
that we picked out that shows a field
hospital in belarus all the indications
includes of a possible imminent invasion
how might that invasion look well the
feeling amongst western intelligence
officials is that they will move quickly
to try and take the capital kiev and
decapitate the political military
leadership you've also got ukraine's
best forces that have been stationed in
the east of the country so they would
try and cut them off and stop them
coming back to the capital the belief is
that president putin has not yet given
the order to invade but ago no-go
decision
is imminent